[Music]
on this sunday night archbishop desmond
tutu has died
how the human rights icon helped end
apartheid in south africa we will be
free
and lead change in the rest of the world
ontario's surging covert 19 case counts
how the pandemic is impacting this
boxing day
covid cancellations as omicron surges in
the u.s air travel is brought to a
standstill i came in for christmas and i
got stuck here and erasing history
symbols of freedom removed in hong kong
in a sign of beijing's tightening grip
global national reporting tonight
colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with news from south
africa anglican archbishop desmond tutu
has died at age 90. he was an
anti-apartheid leader and a voice of
justice south africa's president called
tutu a patriot without equal ashan
o'shea reports she's remembered around
the world for a life spent fighting for
equality
i'm always a man of hope and i i believe
the best about everybody archbishop
desmond tutu spent a lifetime struggling
for change in south africa optimistic
the apartheid policy in his home country
would end one day and the black south
africans could be treated as equals
justice is going to win
that goodness is going to overcome evil
he was known as south africa's voice of
conscience determined to see the end of
a racial divide
nothing that anyone can do will do
that he was passionate about human
rights uh
for everybody
uh he didn't you know he absolutely
called it as he saw it anywhere he went
anywhere around the world the nobel
peace prize for 1984.
tutu won the highest honors for that
passion insisting he share any credit
it's very heartwarming but then it is
our price
years later tutu received the
presidential medal of freedom from
barack obama who today called tutu a
mentor on moral compass
free at last
tutu began his career as a teacher in
the 60s but in disgust over apartheid
policies setting a course that would
guide the rest of his life
while it was nelson mandela who led
south africa out of apartheid to an era
of reconciliation tutu never stopped
pushing as soon as the new government
was formed there was desmond tutu
criticizing the new government credence
and saying still problems with human
rights still issues with corruption
he said the end of apartheid was a wise
business move the corporations
understood the logic of money
even when they weren't swayed by the
dictates of morality tutu's legacy joy
justice
and peace desmond tutu was 90 years old
sean o'shea global news
to the pandemic now in a grim new record
in ontario for the first time the
province has reported more than 10
thousand new coven 19 cases in a single
day just over 10 400 infections were
reported christmas day another 9 800 new
cases were added today but the true
number of cases is likely much higher as
testing centers are struggling to keep
up morgan campbell reports on the surge
and how it's affecting the holiday
weekend
we have all heard the saying the early
bird gets the worm and taking a look at
this lineup outside best buy in
scarborough that phrase appears to ring
true brian paul got here at 6 30 in the
morning to take advantage of boxing day
sales
usually there's no like good deals and
since it's corona i was expecting not a
lot of people to come out so i was
trying to take advantage of it
many lined up trying to get their hands
on a good deal for some it comes in the
form of something they didn't even know
they needed until they saw it i got the
airfryer actually
so you got a good deal on this yeah not
bad 90 off others lined up with
electronics in mind concerned about
supply chain issues they might still be
on the road on the wharfs outside of bc
and new york city l.a so toronto might
be limited in regards to what we have
here throughout the day similar lines
were found outside stores and malls
across the city ahead of the holidays
the ford government implemented
restrictions not just on family
gatherings but also in restaurants and
of course shopping malls which is why
you are seeing large lineups outside
like this one at vaughan mills the move
was made to help curb the spread of
kevit 19. we cannot underestimate
the emotional psychological impact as we
head into the third year of this and how
deep rooted it is and that it may
absolutely leave scars the number of
qivid 19 cases hit as high as 10 000 in
ontario saturday those record-setting
numbers didn't stop those out looking
for a deal i'm double vaxxed i
go i'm gonna go to the car put hand
sanitizer on not touch my face i'm
wearing my mask that's all i could
really do and for those concerned about
rising numbers or who weren't quite
ready to brave the crowds there was
always the option to shop online for all
of those boxing day sales morgan
campbell global news toronto
in quebec new restrictions are now in
effect as the province tries to get a
hold of skyrocketing cases starting
today private gatherings are limited to
six people or two family bubbles no new
case numbers were released today because
of the holiday but yesterday the
province reported more than 9 200 new
infections
in the u.s surging case numbers are
wreaking havoc on holiday travel
according to a flight tracking website
more than a thousand flights were
canceled in the u.s today alone airlines
say too many crew members have either
tested positive or are in self-isolation
jennifer johnson reports on the impacts
and the warnings across the u.s as
omicron cases spike
from long lines at airports to major
backups at kova 19 testing sites there
was little joy this christmas for
millions of americans many people never
got to celebrate the holiday with their
relatives i came in for christmas and i
got stuck here thousands of flights had
to be cancelled as the fast spreading
omicron variant sickened airline staff
members not surprising they have so much
public contact that folks despite best
efforts
are coming down with the virus thousands
of other americans were stuck in long
lines waiting to get tested for cobia 19
only to be turned away hours later
because sites ran out of tests like the
grinch just walked over and talked
after hours of waiting the lucky ones
who could get tested felt like they hit
the lottery this is the very best
christmas present
i could ever have in my life the u.s has
seen over 52 million covet 19 infections
daily one day records continue to be
shattered in places like new york and
florida doctors fear what will happen to
america's healthcare system as the virus
spreads realize it affects pharmacists
it affects the people who are delivering
medications and supplies to cancer
patients that need treatment we're
seeing this all across the line some
hospitals are so overcrowded patients
are being treated in hallways and
parking lot tents over 80 percent of
those in intensive care are unvaccinated
i can't believe that
i didn't get the shot
and i will be getting one
because i don't want to do this again
regrets from at least one patient as
roughly 15 percent of eligible adult
americans still refuse to get vaccinated
jennifer johnson global news washington
a medical mix up in australia coming up
why a copic 19 testing lab is
apologizing to hundreds of people
a major medical lab in sydney australia
is apologizing after telling hundreds of
people they tested negative for covet 19
when they were actually positive the lab
says 400 people were affected it blamed
human error for the mistake in recent
days parts of australia have seen a
major surge in cases driven by omicron
today new south wales set a new case
record and hospitalizations are also
rising
new restrictions are now in effect
across large parts of the u.k in
scotland new capacity limits took effect
today for indoor and outdoor events in
wales and northern ireland nightclubs
have been closed no new restrictions
were imposed in england despite
skyrocketing infections there are
reports more measures could be decided
on this week
what happened in federal politics this
year ahead our ottawa bureau looks back
at 2021
you're watching global national
with less than a week to go until 2022
it's time to look back at the year that
was in canadian politics from covet 19
and truth and reconciliation to climate
change and the fall federal election a
lot happened in 2021. let's go to
mercedes stevenson and our political
correspondents in ottawa for the moments
that stood out
what a year
2021 brought to us indeed one dominated
yet again by the covid19 pandemic
2021 started out with the hope of new
vaccines the rollout was slow at first
leading to more lockdowns in the spring
by june 20 percent of canadians were
fully vaccinated by july nearly 80
percent of canadians had received a
first vaccine dose so in august the
trudeau government decided to head to
the polls hoping to get a majority but
they got the same result as 2019 and we
end the year in much the same way that
we started it with talks of lockdowns
restrictions and another pandemic wave
something certainly canadians don't want
to talk about but here we find ourselves
and we're going to be talking about it
with our political correspondence here
in ottawa joining me is our chief
political correspondent david aiken he's
on remote because we're being very
careful in these
new variant times and here in the studio
with me are parliamentary correspondents
michael couture and abigail beeman both
six feet away from me six feet away from
each other we're being very careful here
you know i think last year we all
thought that we would get to this year
and hopefully not still be talking about
covet 19 as the big story there's been a
lot of stories though this year the
election which also had coveted under
hones military sexual misconduct how the
conservatives performed all of these
things coming out we want to find out
your real opinions on covering these
stories because we see the side in front
of the news but we don't always get to
hear those behind the scenes stories and
how we process things as reporters david
let's start with you what was the
standout story for you of 2021
it has to be the federal election and
the results aside it's the very fact
that we had an election an election
especially when we look around the world
and to our neighbors in the south that
none of the participants challenged the
validity of the election
no candidate no party
no voter
we carried off an election in which by
and large uh there is no questions about
the legitimacy there's some issues about
people in in some northern first nations
communities didn't have polling places
that needs to be tended to but i think
it's a highlight that we got through a
federal pandemic election
safely by and large with no questions
about the legitimacy and i think that's
a testament largely to the elections
canada folks i know who were under a lot
of pressure and and had to work hard to
pull off
338 separate races involving thousands
of candidates in very trying conditions
so i'd say that's a highlight and it
follows other elections too in nova
scotia they had a provincial election
same thing safe and and worked
newfoundland labrador they had some
hiccups they had some lockdowns couldn't
do in person and voting back there in
february but we can do elections here in
canada safely in a pandemic where people
are not questioning the legitimacy of
the results
yeah and certainly something that was a
big question mark how that election
would unfold given all of the
restrictions and given what we saw our
southern neighbors just go through
abigail what was the standout story for
you this year for me i think it was the
pandemic and you know you you say it
exactly right that there were a lot of
people hoping that we wouldn't still be
talking about this as a headline at this
point but uh the the issues of of how do
you have a hybrid parliament and how
much are parties going to work together
and how much will politics play into
that we're still dealing with that
pandemic we're still having these you
know weekly or sometimes more updates
from public health this is still top of
mind it's still affecting so many
people's lives that for me it stood out
and also this sense of of things feeling
the same i mean
david touched on the the idea of the
election turning out the same result but
we're we're in essentially the same
place in terms of the the breakdown in
the house from parties and it feels very
much like we're in the same place uh in
terms of of covet and and having these
same conversations about restrictions
and and the state of things so this idea
of sameness i think stands out for me
across 2021 both on the politics and on
the public health front yeah it really
does feel um a little bit like the song
that never ends or groundhog day
whatever your cultural comparison is um
that a lot of us are still processing
march 2020 i think i feel like i'm still
in april of 2020 but at the end of 2021
mike what stood out for you yeah i think
you know to everybody's point yeah covet
19 the election i'm gonna go off the
board for a second here and i think the
highlight for me was unanimous consent
on conversion therapy that was something
that i think nobody expected in this
parliament we came back to parliament
with the same result as 2019 and a lot
of people looked at and went well now
we're going to have the same political
games and then somehow the day that it
came on the floor of the house of
commons the conservatives surprised
everybody and call for a
vote on unanimous consent to pass
conversion therapy why i think this is
important not only because i covered the
story but the ramifications of this one
that the conservatives were trying to
put this issue behind them so that it
wouldn't continue to hang over them to
speaking to survivors of it and doing
the story so touching to hear from these
people who said that this is so
important to them to finally get through
this to finally have this being illegal
on the books and not only that it
happened in the house of commons
unanimous consent also in the senate
that how quickly this was passed maybe
gives me a little bit of hope going into
the new year that potentially this
parliament can work towards a better end
for canadians and you know talking to
that survivor exchanging emails with him
after it was passed how shocked he was
but so happy he was that this is finally
passed through the house certainly a big
relief to a lot of people and a rare
showing of not just bipartisan but all
party support for this for something
that people really felt needed to happen
and was the right thing it's always nice
in politics when they're not squabbling
and they come together on important
issues david do you think we're going to
see that trend continue or is it going
to devolve into more partisan bickering
as we head into 2022
there was a different kind of partisan
bickering and it's it's from those who
are very angry at the current public
health environment and again this goes
back to the election all of us were out
on the road with various leaders we
traveled around the country and uh you
know uh abigail i think was there when
people were throwing rocks at the prime
minister some of which hit members of
the media we were all there to watch
angry mobs
using the most foul-mouthed obscenities
often with kids in their arms yelling at
political candidates didn't matter the
candidate it was new democrats it was
liberals
i know conservative premiers were
experiencing this same sort of threats
of violence i've talked to mps of all
parties who say they've never seen an
electorate so angry anger turning into
threats threats sometimes turning into
violence we're going to have an election
in ontario next year in 2022 and i know
that doug ford's conservatives they're
the incumbent uh and they've been you
know right there in lockstep with every
other province imposing lockdowns and
public health measures to keep us safe
and they are expecting to see the same
kind of angry mobs at their rallies that
justin trudeau's liberals saw at theirs
so that was a low light for 2021 and
that's something to keep an eye on for
2022.
abigail you were there you experienced
it do you think that this is going to
continue into the next year
you know i i don't want to make any
predictions there because it was just so
uh incomprehensible to watch in turn
just in terms not not incompetent
comprehensible that people are
frustrated not incomprehensible that
people are fed up with what's going on
but you know david touched on it to see
this level of anger is something i've
never witnessed before to to feel that
tension in those crowds we all we all
knew that at some point this was going
to escalate you talk about the the rock
or the gravel or however you want to
describe what was thrown through the the
crowds that that evening but we all
could sense that that there was going to
be an escalation there just because of
the level of vitriol and and the the
constant profanity and like you say you
know people holding babies and just
screaming their heads off with such a
level of anger so i you know i hope that
that we don't see that again going
forward but i certainly uh you know was
was caught off guard by the the level of
intensity and and how long it lasted for
that i wouldn't want to make a
prediction going forward mike finally
yeah i'm a little concerned that this is
a line that we've crossed now and that
people think that this is going to be
permissible going forward and that uh
looking at how it all played out i mean
abigail you were there everybody who you
know was on that liberal campaign
felt that vitriol from people and and
you know understanding that people now
feel like they have the ability to do
this and they're allowed to do this and
i hope that we can all take away from
this campaign that we look at and go no
that was the line that we will never
cross again unfortunately i don't have a
lot of faith in that because i think
that people think
you know i did it once i can do this
again because i have a voice i'm allowed
to do this and i'm allowed to do this as
you said in front of kids and i'm really
worried that going ahead in
future elections that people are going
to say hey i'm going to do this again
yeah i think that we're all concerned
and we all hope for a better 2022 in
many ways let's hope that when we're
back here a year from now it's not
another covid19 discussion maybe our
politics are a little bit more positive
thank you to the three of you for
joining us and for all your hard work
this year
colleen back to you mercedes stevenson
thank you
next why universities in hong kong are
removing monuments that mark the
tiananmen massacre
another sign things are changing in hong
kong three universities this week
removed works of art public monuments
commemorating the 1989 tiananmen
massacre they're the latest examples of
the chinese government's crackdown on
political dissent and a further erosion
of the one country two systems principle
that was supposed to apply to hong kong
mike armstrong explains
it is part of an effort some have said
to erase public memory early thursday
morning crews worked behind barriers
watched by guards dismantling a monument
the danish sculptor who created the work
says he was shocked in the middle of the
night 12 o'clock in hong kong just
one day before christmas evening
i think it's a really brutal way to do
this kind of thing it really really puts
that way
video that was shot it appears the
monument was cut apart packed up in
pieces and then put in a container the
spot where it stood for 24 years is now
empty
this man says the government is trying
to wipe out history people he says have
to fight against forgetting
it was called the pillar of shame an
eight meter tall sculpture depicting
twisted and pained bodies representing
the victims of the tiananmen massacre
in 1989 chinese troops broke up
demonstrations in beijing calling for
greater political freedoms the
government would say 200 civilians were
killed others have said the number was
closer to ten thousand
for decades there were vigils in hong
kong to mark the anniversary two years
ago they were banned as they are in
mainland china instead students
protested by cleaning the artwork other
vigils were larger thousands marched
despite the ban but dozens of activists
and politicians were arrested and
prosecuted
now two other hong kong universities
have also removed artwork inspired by
the tiananmen crackdown a painting at
one university was painted over and
another two monuments were pulled down a
statue that had been in this park and a
monument that had been on this wall the
artist responsible for both says they
were removed at night as though by
thieves
he says the universities and the
government are trying to get rid of
parts of history it's made him feel he
says as though the rule of law and
freedom in hong kong are
mike armstrong global news
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm colleen christie we
leave you tonight with images from the
remarkable life of archbishop desmond
tutu the nobel peace prize winner and
racial justice activist died today in
cape town south africa he was 90 years
old
thanks for watching hope you'll join us
here again tomorrow
good night
you